[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> I'm in denial.
I don't want to face the reality that
my time at the GSB is coming to an end.
But that's what's happened.
That's the harsh reality.
And I have to decide,
where am I going to go next?
Perhaps some of you can relate.
I was going to go back to the Midwest,
it's where I'm from originally.
I grew up on a farm in Nebraska,
enjoyed playing outside,
had a tight knit community
that supported me.
I even got to exhibit pigs at the county
fair in the summer, what a life.
And later I moved to Minnesota for work,
and I fell in love with the culture,
people that are so polite,
kind, and reserved.
Even have a special term for it, it's
called Minnesota nice, it's a real thing.
But believe it or not,
the Midwest actually hasn't been
a popular destination for GSB alums.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now I have been working on my
art skills, and for an illustration here,
I've created an exact
replica of the United States.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I looked back at where last
year's class ended up.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Right there.
>> You can see the distribution.
We have quite a few in Silicon Valley and
New York,
maybe even a few cowboys and
cowgirls in Texas, but
a huge hole in between,
only about 2% were going to the Midwest.
But I kept hope.
Maybe our class would be different.
So I sent a survey to my classmates.
60 responded, and of that 60, 0 were
going to the Midwest after graduation.
Common reasons included things like it's
too cold, the culture is too conservative,
there's nothing to do from a social or
professional aspect, and
I don't have ties to the region,
so why should I go?
I started to reflect.
I mean, was I missing something here?
Should I not be going to the Midwest?
Perhaps people were missing out on
an opportunity by not even considering it.
So I decided to take a fresh look at the
region in terms of career opportunities,
quality of life, and
potential for societal impact.
First from a career standpoint, I know
we all have extremely high aspirations,
so I looked at what past alums have done,
and
what they did to become
the most successful.
For instance,
Phil Knight didn't stay in Silicon Valley.
He went to Beaverton,
Oregon to build Nike.
Mary Barra, she went to Detroit
to work for General Motors,
eventually becoming CEO and
Fortune's most powerful woman in business.
So perhaps there is a benefit to going
somewhere where everyone else isn't.
For further research I spoke with Robert
Hadda, he's a partner at Drive Capital,
it's a VC firm focused on
funding Midwest startups.
It was founded by two former Sequoia
partners who left Silicon Valley for
Columbus, Ohio, of all places, because of
the opportunities they saw in the region.
Part of that is, it's a very big economy.
You have a quarter the Fortune
500 companies in the region.
So for those GSB students who want to
work for a large company right away,
there's ample opportunities in
broad industries that truly matter.
Things like healthcare,
financial services, food and agriculture.
For those who want to do something
maybe a little more exciting,
there's even a budding startup scene.
One of the benefits of being the region
as a startup is you're close to many
of your end consumers and competitors.
So you're able to respond, and
learn from them more quickly.
There's also a lot of top
state schools in the region.
So you're able to draw from top talent
in computer science and engineering,
without competing with companies
like Facebook and Google.
Specifically as GSBs, we have
the opportunity to take some of the best
practices that we learned at Stanford and
Silicon Valley and
bring them to the region to help grow it.
Things like rapid product development,
and scaling, building world class teams,
that because of current technology
you can do from anywhere.
So, who knows?
Maybe we can even apply some of
those touchy feely skills and
we'll build the first corn
unicorn in the region.
Sounds great.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I also spoke with David Kit.
He lived in Chicago and Minneapolis and
was my alumni interviewer.
He worked in finance and e-commerce.
And he pointed out that being somewhere
where there's a relatively smaller network
is actually powerful.
Those who are in the region become closer.
And you can leverage that network more.
As an employee,
you become more powerful to your employer.
Because you might be one of the few who
can tap into the broader Stanford network.
It's a good situation to be in.
So outside just the career aspects though,
there is quality of life to consider.
Fast forward, say, five years.
You're ready to settle down,
married, perhaps have a kid.
Hopefully you've even
made your first million.
Well, maybe you want to buy a house with
that, but if you're in San Francisco-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Something like that,
kind of a fixer-upper.
Instead, say you decide
to go to Minneapolis.
You end up with something like this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Prime lakefront property.
Your choice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now,
it's not just the housing that's awesome.
Recently did a study looking in terms of
overall quality of life from the aspects
of affordability, economic opportunity,
and work life balance.
All five of the top cities in
its study were from the Midwest.
Places like Saint Paul, Minnesota,
Lincoln, Nebraska and Madison, Wisconsin.
There is a benefit, too, of going
somewhere where there is slightly fewer
people, because it makes
activities more accessible to you.
If you want to get reservations to your
favorite restaurant, say, it's easier.
Same with concert tickets and
sporting events.
It's a great time to be in
the region as well for sports.
I mean, you have the World Series
champion Chicago Cubs, and as knows,
the NBA champion Cleveland Cavaliers.
Apologies to the Golden State fans,
I realize you're a little
sad your reign's over.
But it's okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know we also had
a few foodies in the room.
There's tons of farms in the area,
in case you didn't know.
So you can eat farm fresh and
local, constantly.
And trust me,
if you're a carnivore like me, there's
no better place in the world for steaks.
I love it.
But it's not just about the food.
The thing I miss most, not being
in the region now, is the people.
I had the honor of having one of
my classmates, Michael, visit,
he's Nigerian, over winter break.
The thing that surprised him most was how
open and welcoming the people were in
the region, something
Midwesterners pride themselves on.
You say hi and wave to strangers.
It's kind of strange at first,
but you get used to it.
If you haven't visited, I suggest you
do and you'll notice the difference.
Now, in terms of societal impact,
collectively,
I do think our decisions matter.
A popular topic at the moment for
instance is the divide that's
developed in our country.
Much of that is geographic based,
the coasts and Middle America.
Well, call me crazy, but I don't
think that's going away anytime soon,
if we just stay in Silicon Valley and
New York.
If you want to see a change in a region,
why not move there?
Bring it.
If you think people have been left behind,
try to bring them new
economic opportunities.
I realize there might be some resistance,
being like, these people are different
from me, I don't know how to connect.
But from my experience in
living in both regions,
there's more similarities
than differences.
It's also enjoyable to
hear a variety of thought.
That's how you truly learn to
understand one another and
find common ground to connect.
After talking through and
reflecting on my decision, I am confident
that I do want to go to the Midwest.
If you're still deciding and
want to be able stand out in your career,
have an exceptional quality of life, and
help to unify our country, then join me.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]